we had it from January 21st 1976 to
October 24th 2003 we had a commercial
supersonic passenger plane called
Concorde today it takes seven hours to
fly from New York to London on the
Concorde it took about three hours and
30 minutes just under three hours if it
was record time a journey that would
have taken the Titanic 137 hours had
become just barely long enough to watch
Titanic while crossing the Atlantic the
Concorde came to represent class style
and the miracle of Engineering here's a
normal plane landing and here's the
Concorde landing which one are you
looking at with Concorde we all looked
up and pointed and then in 2003 it
stopped
we had commercial supersonic flight and
just let it go why why did the Concorde
become a museum exhibit this is the
Smithsonian's Concorde and the curator
who got it flew on it - I did see you
know the color of the sky at 60,000 feet
is this most gorgeous deep deep purple
how did it break through become a piece
of memorabilia the answer says something
about how innovation really sticks and
it's complicated I've got a personal
interest in the FFT and I'd like to tell
you about it SS T equals supersonic
transport any transportation that's
faster than the speed of sound it became
a dream after Chuck Yeager broke the
sound barrier in 1947 and a
technological race in the 1950s and
1960s combined Cold War competition with
a classic mid-century faith in
engineering Americans Russians and the
British and French governments dumped
hundreds of millions of dollars into
supersonic R&D think rooms full of
engineers in short sleeves and ties the
event Seattle based Boeing won the
American design contract in 1967 that's
where a certain basketball team got its
original name
the development stopped after a 1971
funding cut Russia's effort the tupolev
tu-144 flew but it was grounded after an
extraordinarily spotty record over just
55 flights but there was a winner the
paper da jetliner conceived jointly by
Britain and France to shrink the world
and cut air journey times in half from
the beginning Concorde was a marvel of
design it wasn't designed with computers
but through math and trial and error
they had to innovate constantly to make
a supersonic passenger plane possible
the airplane needed to be very long and
narrow goes supersonically comfortably
and the paint was twice as reflective as
other jets just to compensate for the
heat from air friction cause you're
traveling at Mach tune twice the speed
of sound even though you're at 60,000
feet the airframe would actually heat up
dramatically
so I actually you know touch the window
it wasn't warm it was hot fuel flowed
around the plane during flight to adjust
its center of gravity for takeoff
cruising and landing so these pumps are
working the whole flight but we can't
tell but it was the beautiful wing that
distinguished the Concorde for its
greatest fans it's a delta wing but it's
called an oak I hold delta wing because
of its unique shape Delta because it was
triangular like the Greek Delta Oh gavel
to reference its curved the delta wing
helped the concorde get lift at takeoff
and limit drag while in flight the rest
of the plane compensated the one
compromise in it required the aircraft
to have a very high angle of attack on
takeoff and landing since pilots
couldn't see out of the plane because of
angled landing engineers put together a
solution the Concorde featured a droop
snoot droop snoot yeah the sneak would
droop the snoot Ruth the reason being
that it was a delta wing design and they
had a very high angle of attack on
landing so in order to see they were
able to lower the nose
we flew at Mach 2 more than 1300 miles
an hour faster than the Earth spins um
you couldn't tell the only way you knew
you could you're doing Mach 2 was that
they had a Mach meter up on the bulkhead
then everybody was focused on that
because it would creep up and Susan what
Mach 1 everybody break out into applause
to minimize drag its soared so high you
could see the Earth's curve the Concorde
defined the glamour of high speed flight
now this is a very important part of the
70s wardrobe which washable bed the -
where's in hot climate and it had the
admiration of celebrities like sting I
was exciting flying supersonic and it
was exciting to get to New York
it was a stratospheric cocktail party
normally people complain about how bad
the airline food is I will attest in
this case that was not true this is one
of the best meals I ever had it worked
beautifully you know a normal French
meal takes two and a half three hours
well by the time dinner was over we were
here so what went wrong on July 25th
2000 the Concorde punctured attire
during takeoff for Air France flight 45
90 135 happened shortly after takeoff it
was due to a problem specific to
Concorde tires the plane was grounded
until November of 2001 by that time the
September 11th attacks had already
depressed the industry but while both
tragedies did affect Concorde there only
a couple of pieces of the fundamental
challenges for the plane noise levels on
takeoff were high but massive super
sonic booms had no comparison in the 60s
the air force ran a test of sonic booms
over Oklahoma City and residents
reported hundreds of damaged windows and
noise disturbances all that meant
limiting supersonic flight to above the
ocean there would be no New York to la
Concorde that's part of what quashed the
American supersonic experiment with
Boeing and it limited demand for
supersonic planes from the beginning
noise concerns were paired with
environmental concerns there will be
severe environmental damage to the ozone
layer the planes high flight pattern
made scientists think its exhaust gas
could be more threatening to the ozone
than normal Jets what was noticeable was
that you kept climbing and climbing and
climbing
we're flying much higher than a normal
airliner a massive fleet of supersonic
planes probably would have caused real
damage setting red flags for a
supersonic future fuel requirements also
limited range to transatlantic journeys
without any trains Pacific cash cows it
guzzled enough fuel that price
fluctuations could hit particularly hard
with ticket prices as high as twelve
thousand dollars a seat
that was a significant risk and tickets
had to be expensive since at most only a
hundred twenty passengers could fit on
the plane it couldn't distribute the
price tag that was compounded by the
need for specially qualified crew
members and maintenance that came at a
premium and it was all for a very
demanding crowd
Air France and num and British Airways
had to position a spare concorde in New
York in case the the flight back had
problems so there's airplane sitting on
the ground not making any money just in
case because Concorde passengers expect
you know to walk onto a Concorde but
could they paid a lot of money to it
none of these factors stop the Concorde
but they all boxed it in until it had
nowhere to go but down when Air France
and British Airways announced the
Conchords closing on April 10th 2003 it
wasn't about the past but the future the
manufacturer Airbus decided supporting
the Concorde was impossible in ageing
Concorde it's still at analog controls
and a flight engineer both of which
newer planes had lost would cost too
much to upgrade or redo in a way
Conchords economics were similar to this
toy models economics I got it for 10
bucks because the manufacturer could
distribute the cost of factory workers
tooling and distribution over thousands
of cube planes Airbus loves doing the
same with its family of jets even if a
flight were profitable for an airline
the airline couldn't afford a new small
batch of airplanes all the factors that
box in Concorde kept its scale so small
it would be wildly unprofitable to
service rebuild or revive the best
option was to land for good
we like to think breakthroughs on the
end because of disaster with a crash but
they can fall short without disaster
despite a breathtaking way nor a
jaw-dropping droop snoot they have to
come with a business model and supply
system a political resolve in a plan to
expand even as future dreams for
supersonic transport simmer all those
business model questions remain
unanswered
they don't exist unless they make money
some people don't like that idea but
it's a fact of life
they're there to make money and if
they're making a product that doesn't
make them money they'll either stop
making it or they'll go out of business
or both you never know so the flight
time to London can return to a double
feature slog but we lose something with
the drudgery progress slows and we have
to wait for something else to look up at
something worth pointing at
so I have fallen completely in love with
the Concord but it was not that
comfortable of a ride Bob told me that
while the legroom was pretty good the
Headroom was not and neither was the
seat width it was kind of like a coach
seat and you can see that in this video
of sting
he looks pretty cramped especially for
staying
you